it was a big disappointment obviously
hillary duff is opening up about the
lizzie mcguire revival series that
never happened it's fine really
i'm not the cheerleader type i'm i'm
more of a
pancake during hillary's appearance on
good morning america wednesday
the 33 year old actress who starred in
the original disney channel series from
2001 to 2004
and announced in 2019 that she'd be
returning for the revival series
revealed what she hopes her beloved
character lizzie mcguire would be up to
today
i think she would be quirky i think that
she would
struggle with confidence but i think at
the end of the day
she finds her footing that's what's so
lovely about her
and that's what's so relatable is that
she doesn't have all the answers right
away
but eventually she's on the right path
and she opened up about the revival
ultimately getting scrapped after they
shot a few episodes
it was a big disappointment obviously i
will forever be grateful for the two
episodes that we did shoot
it was a really special
two weeks of my life it was first
announced in august 2019
that lizzie mcguire would be returning
to our screens on disney plus
but in 2018 hillary shared this
tease with e.t you recently said that
you would love to revisit
lizzie mcguire it's been over 15 years
since the movie
came out have there been any
conversations
yes yes conversation where do you think
lizzie would be these days
there's been lots of conversations about
that so i don't know i'm i'm
i'm racking my brain i don't i don't
think she's a mom yet but
she might be getting there soon um
yeah it's fun i feel i feel excited and
you know i don't really know that it
could be a possibility or it could be
nothing so we'll see after the big news
was officially confirmed as a go
hillary revealed what it was like to
revisit her iconic role
now in her 30s it feels very surreal
to be honest i mean i've been living
with this information for a few months
now
so it's been very hard to even contain
my excitement
um but you know she's such a big part of
me in my life
and you know now she's 30 and i feel
like i'm gonna have to learn some of
like her quirky faces again
um but i'm i'm excited the premise of
the revival series
lizzie is all grown up and navigating
life in new york city
on the cusp of her 30th birthday working
her dream job as the apprentice to a top
designer
and dating her dream man and in my world
lizzie and ethan have always been end
game
i love the way even says my name lizzy
lizzy
lizzy lizzy lizzy lizzy lizzy and yes
she still had 13 year old animated
lizzie blabbering around in her head
it's really it's a dream come true but
back in december
hill took to instagram to announce that
the new series was
no longer happening writing in part
quote
i want any reboot of lizzie to be honest
and authentic to who lizzy would be
today
it's what the character deserves i'm
very sad but i promise
everyone tried their best and the stars
just didn't align
[Music]
you